the first round of qualifiers for the
vct is over but we did not get through
it without some drama one of the most
exciting teams in north america was
disqualified after a coach was found to
have sent messages to players in the
middle of games
two little words were sent that have
caused more drama in the valor community
than we have seen in weeks
help sewer
[Music]
all right before we get into the video i
gotta remind you as always the like
button the subscribe button and to ring
the notification bell so if you missed
it this past weekend the vct had their
first open qualifiers where teams like
tsm faze discord kittens and girl
kissers
all competed to qualify for spots for
the group stage of n a challengers one
but one team in particular t1 was
disqualified from the event so you may
ask how did this happen tsm and t1 faced
off on january 29th in the fourth round
of the lower bracket and everyone was
pretty curious to see how these newly
constructed teams would shape up the
first map was split won by t1 13 to 7.
tsm subrosa then quote tweeted his
teammate alekko levi who was talking
about paying and sabrosa said the
following i'm playing versus a team that
has their coach typing and probably
talking to them mid-game gg6v5 soon
after he adds it's okay guys they got a
warning if you're like hmm this sounds a
bit fishy
it's because it is per vct rules coaches
are only allowed to talk to their team
during specific times
during rounds is not one of those times
so map two icebox comes around and we
get to the half eight four with t1
leading and then we see this appear on
screen tech pause
tbd which is fine tech pauses happen all
the time but this tech pause was taking
40 minutes without any sort of worried
about what was happening we get some
yawning emojis from tsm which doesn't
really give us much to go off of we got
tweets from t1 players a yawning emoji
from steel and unlucky from seven and
some ggwps from the tsm players of
wardell and sabrosa a little bit later
tiwan's curry said he might be the most
unlucky player in na valorant history at
this point people didn't have a clue
what was going on all that we knew was
the map was no longer being played they
said they were made aware that a t1
coach was communicating with players
during the game not during pauses or
timeouts when they're allowed to
specifically they broke rule 7.2.11
unauthorized communications riot forced
t1 to forfeit the match and they were
out of the qualifier via elimination on
february 1st t1 made the decision to
suspend their valorem head coach david
dennis for the next open qualifier for
what had occurred that same day david
dennis made a formal apology via twitter
saying the following the communication
logs show that all communication i had
with players happened between rounds or
to a player who was already eliminated
this communication consisted of
encouraging supportive statements and
general reminders one exception to this
was help sewers there are no excuses for
this i can only say that i got caught up
in the heat of the moment and did not
think before i acted i did not
participate in the practice of watching
the live stream during a match or
relaying any information to the players
that they did not already have at the
time all we knew was that a coach had
accidentally typed in all chat after the
match bordell shed some light on what
exactly was said two little words on
twitter help sewer the first map that
was played split is the only map that
has the sewers call out and obviously a
coach telling a team to help any area of
the map during a game would not be okay
people were shocked and it didn't take
long for help sewer memes to flood the
timeline also according to sabrosa the
coach also said rosa alt again we don't
know what the context for this was now
after the dust had settled with the t1
versus tsm match and the forfeit
happened wardell made the accusation
that he thought t1 players were using
vpns during the match why were you on
texas servers because those guys were
using vpns
they were using vpn to like make their
ping higher and [ __ ] disgusting
they have two people on five ping and
the ping difference is [ __ ]
lower than chicago like how does that
even work makes no sense this guy's like
he's using a vpn and then they ask him
yo what ping do you have without your
vpn
and then levi is like why does he just
take it off and show us and i'm like yo
that's a great idea instead of just
telling us
bro i'm like yo this is so sketch
however according to a member of nerd
street the torment operators this has no
merit they stated that service selection
was done according to the vct rule set
and the most fair server was chosen for
this matchup and now i promise you
that's it for the drama because if we
have learned anything this weekend n a
valerian cannot get it together whether
it's in the server or on twitter so
where are we now that the dust has
settled well t1 still has a chance to
qualify in the next open qualifier tsm
failed to qualify this weekend while
energy exit version 1 and the guard have
but they'll have a shot next time around
there have been a lot of comparisons
with this to the g2 esports situation in
january in which a coach is thought to
be heard on voice comms but no
punishment or sanctioning was made this
has led some people to suggest that
there has been an uneven enforcement of
rules from riot i want to bring your
attention to a tweet that summarizes how
i really feel about all of this i wonder
how many coaches are illegally
communicating during matches if a rule
is completely unenforceable i would
expect a significantly higher likelihood
of that rule being broken as far as i
can tell we only know this happened
because a coach messed up if riot had
not been made aware of that
communication we most likely would not
have known tdk brings us up in another
tweet but it's also kind of scary to
think that this might be a widespread
issue that some people are okay with the
reason i say it's scary because if in
this esport we are creating an
environment in which this is acceptable
behavior some teams will abuse it others
won't and that creates an uneven playing
field liz is just typing in all chat
okay it's still cheating it's still
finding an unfair competitive advantage
it means that people find little to no
issue with this happening if you think
this isn't a big deal or whatever i just
ask you one thing
where do you draw the line
i feel like you're a karaoke menace
danny am i right
i was thinking about karaoke the child
this morning actually
your go-to karaoke song
this is what i was thinking
about how i don't actually
have any prepared like i i just sort of
like flick through the book and
see what i like oh man
i need to like have like a set piece you
know five
i have
one and it's amy winehouse
rehab
that's the one i will belt out